« L’art contemporain est-il nul ? »
Ce n’est pas moi qui pose la question — c’est
Jean Baudrillard, le mythique penseur de la
société de consommation et du film Matrix.
Il pose cette question dans le quotidien Libération
en novembre 1996, et dans l’heure qui suit
la publication, le Tout-Paris de l’art est
en ébullition.
La polémique durera six bons mois, au cours
desquels les partisans de l’art contemporain
assimileront parfois les détracteurs à des
fascistes.
Jean Baudrillard a déclenché un des plus
violents affrontements idéologiques sur l’art
contemporain.
Il faut dire qu’il n’y va pas de main
morte : « L’art contemporain spécule sur
la culpabilité de ceux qui n’y comprennent
rien ou qui n’ont pas compris qu’il n’y
avait rien à comprendre ».
Avec le recul, la polémique créée par Jean
Baudrillard semble appartenir à la tradition
française du débat sur l’art, qui remonte
(au moins) à la querelle des Anciens et des
Modernes de la fin du XVIIe siècle.
Mais la polémique est aussi révélatrice
d’un malaise.
En effet, beaucoup de gens — y compris parmi
les initiés du monde de la culture — pensent
comme Baudrillard qu’il y a un problème
fondamental avec ce qu’on appelle l’«
art contemporain », c’est-à-dire l’ère
de l’histoire de l’art occidental qu’on
fait conventionnellement commencer la Seconde
Guerre mondiale (même si l’esprit de l’art
contemporain est déjà présent dans certaines
œuvres, chez certains artistes et certains
mouvements du début du XXe siècle).
Alors, je ne suis pas moi-même un EXPERT
de l’art contemporain, mais je m’y intéresse
depuis pas mal d’années, et j’ai beaucoup
lu sur le sujet cette année pour créer la
vidéo sur l’art contemporain de mon programme
de culture générale Culture Express.
Pour vous aider à comprendre les critiques
des détracteurs, je vais vous présenter
les trois arguments les plus forts CONTRE
l’art contemporain.
Écoutez-moi attentivement JUSQU’AU BOUT,
et vous pourrez critiquer l’art contemporain
sans passer pour un beauf.
Si vous vous êtes baladé place Vendôme,
une des places les plus luxueuses au monde,
au centre de Paris — si vous vous y êtes
baladé à la mi octobre 2014, vous avez pu
apercevoir ça :
C’est une œuvre d’art contemporain du
plasticien américain de Los Angeles Paul
McCarthy. Il l’a intitulée « Tree », mais
il avoue que ce n’est pas à un arbre qu’il
pensait au départ.
Je le cite : « «Tout est parti d'une plaisanterie
: à l'origine, je trouvais que le plug anal
avait une forme similaire aux sculptures de
Brancusi [un sculpteur important du début
du XXe siècle]. Après, je me suis rendu
compte que cela ressemblait à un arbre de
Noël. »
Donc nous avons bien affaire à… un sex-toy
géant.
Quel est le problème ?
Le problème, ce n’est pas que les sex-toy
c’est mal.
Le problème, c’est que la création semble
essentiellement motivée par la transgression.
Le but de l’artiste est de choquer la morale
sociale afin de capter l’attention de l’opinion
publique, et ainsi décupler sa notoriété.
Et cela a fonctionné : le plug géant a scandalisé
une partie de la population ; il a été vandalisé
(en même temps, ce n’est pas très difficile,
vu que c’est une sculpture gonflable) ; l’artiste
lui-même, Paul McCarthy, a été agressé
— et les médias ont bien sûr relayé cette
histoire insolite (en la présentant souvent
comme un conflit entre les conservateurs et
les progressistes, et en taisant la logique
marketing).
Dans cet exemple, l’« œuvre » doit donc
sa célébrité à son impudeur. Paul McCarthy
s’est défendu en disant que c’est de
l’art abstrait, mais il savait très bien
que le public allait imaginer des choses très
concrètes en voyant son arbre abstrait.
Voici donc le premier argument contre l’art
contemporain : l’artiste manipule l’opinion
publique.
Dans cette perspective, il est davantage un
communiquant, presque un marketeur. Il se
sert des biais psychologiques de l’être
humain pour conquérir ce qui a une immense
valeur dans nos sociétés de l’information,
l’attention du public.
C’est ce qui fait écrire à Baudrillard
: « L’œuvre, c’est sa diffusion médiatique
».
Après, on peut relativiser cet argument en
estimant que le plug géant est plutôt un
exemple des excès de l’art contemporain,
et que la démarche de l’artiste ne se résume
pas à la manipulation de l’opinion publique.
On peut encore affaiblir l’argument en considérant
que la transgression est un ingrédient de
l’art occidental grosso modo depuis le XIXe
siècle.
Oui mais… attendez l’argument suivant.
100 millions de dollars !
100 millions de dollars, c’était le prix
de vente (en 2007) de ce crâne sculpté par
Damian Hirst, l’artiste britannique le plus
célèbre de l’art contemporain.
Il a intitulé cette création « For the
Love of God » (« Pour l’amour de Dieu
», en français). C’est une réplique du
véritable crâne d’un homme du XVIIIe siècle
qui était mort grosso modo à mon âge.
100 millions de dollars pour ça, c’est
énorme — mais il faut prendre en compte
le fait que le crâne est incrusté de 8 601
diamants.
Donc ce n’est pas une arnaque.
À un tel prix, on imagine bien qu’il n’y
aura pas la queue devant le magasin. Et c’est
peut-être même trop cher pour une seule
personne : c’est en effet un groupe d’investisseurs
qui a été le premier acquéreur du crâne.
Et parmi ces investisseurs, il y a… Damian
Hirst !
Attendez, c’est pas le nom de l’artiste
?! Ou bien c’est un homonyme ?!
Non non, c’est bien lui !
Un artiste qui s’achète À LUI-MÊME sa
PROPRE œuvre ?!
Mais qu’est-ce que c’est que cette histoire
?!
En fait, l’explication est assez simple
: le crâne était si cher que personne n’en
voulait.
Dans une telle situation, la loi de l’offre
et de la demande fait baisser le prix, jusqu’à
ce quelqu’un soit intéressé à un prix
plus bas. Peut-être qu’à 10 millions,
c’était bon.
Mais voilà : la baisse du prix, ça ne fait
pas les affaires de Damian Hirst !
Donc il a LUI-MÊME acheté l’œuvre — bien
sûr pas pour mettre le crâne sur son bureau,
mais dans l’espoir de le revendre plus cher.
Voici donc le deuxième argument contre l’art
contemporain : l’œuvre est un objet de
spéculation
(certains critiques comparent même les œuvres
d’art contemporain aux produits financiers
à l’origine de la crise de 2008).
Non seulement de riches particuliers et des
fonds d’investissement achètent des créations
dans une optique purement spéculative, mais
les artistes, à l’instar de Damian Hirst,
rentrent eux aussi dans cette logique.
Or, le problème de cette logique, c’est
qu’elle se moque de la valeur d’usage
de l’œuvre.
Dans les ères précédentes de l’histoire
de l’art, l’acheteur était la plupart
du temps un amateur qui avait l’intention
d’embellir son environnement visuel et de
jouir de l’œuvre au quotidien. Mais dans
des créations comme le crâne de Damian Hirst,
c’est la valeur d’ÉCHANGE qui est importante
: ce n’est pas fait pour regarder ; c’est
fait pour acheter et pour vendre.
Après, on peut relativiser cet argument de
la même manière que le premier : j’ai
raisonné à partir d’un exemple extrême.
En réalité, la plupart des œuvres d’art
contemporain ont bien une valeur d’usage
— puisqu’elles sont exposées — et la
spéculation existe dans le marché de l’art
depuis qu’il existe des gens riches qui
trouvent un intérêt aux créations des artistes.
Oui mais… le dernier argument, c’est du
lourd !
Ça, c’est une œuvre d’art ?
Je ne sais pas si vous vous rendez compte,
mais ÇA, c’est un urinoir en porcelaine.
Il a été baptisé « Fontaine » par Marcel
Duchamp, le Français qui est le grand précurseur
de l’art contemporain.
L’exposition new-yorkaise à laquelle il
a proposé cette « œuvre » en 1917 l’a
refusée. Mais l’urinoir a ensuite connu
un destin exceptionnel, jusqu’à devenir
emblématique du XXe siècle dans l’histoire
de l’art.
Bien sûr, le choix d’un urinoir est fait
pour choquer le bourgeois en jouant sur le
tabou des excréments. On peut donc déjà
critiquer le projet avec le premier argument
de cette vidéo.
Mais ce n’est pas cela qui est révélateur
par rapport à l’art contemporain.
Ce qui est révélateur, c’est que Marcel
Duchamp crée avec l’urinoir la mode des
ready-made (« prêt à l'emploi », en français).
Le poète André Breton, le chef de fil du
surréalisme, définit le ready-made dans
son Dictionnaire abrégé du Surréalisme
comme un « objet usuel promu à la dignité
d’objet d’art par le simple choix de l’artiste
».
Si c’est le simple choix de l’artiste
qui promeut un objet à la dignité d’objet
d’art, alors la valeur artistique déserte
l’objet lui-même — c’est ça, le troisième
argument.
La valeur artistique n’est plus intrinsèque
à l’œuvre, mais extrinsèque : ce sont
les autorités culturelles — de l’artiste,
des galeries, des salons, des musées, des
commentateurs, des critiques, etc. — ce
sont ces autorités culturelles qui disent
qu’un urinoir est une œuvre d’art et
imposent, grâce à leur ascendant, cette
idée étonnante au public. En clair, le monde
de l’art dit que telle chose est de l’art,
donc la société considère que c’est de
l’art.
Mais ce qui explique plus fondamentalement
le malaise du public, c’est qu’un ready-made
ne manifeste par définition aucune habileté
supérieure de la part de l’artiste (puisque
c’est un « objet tout fait »). Or, l’habileté
supérieure de la part de l’artiste, c’est
une dimension essentielle de la définition
traditionnelle de l’art (le mot « art » vient
d’ailleurs du latin ars, qui signifie « habileté,
savoir-faire »).
Dans l’émotion esthétique ressentie devant
un tableau de Léonard de Vinci, par exemple,
il y a en partie le respect de la compétence
: « je suis incapable de faire la même chose
».
Or, cette composante disparaît totalement
devant un ready-made de Marcel Duchamp. Sans
le discours intellectuel qui l’accompagne
et le prestige des autorités culturelles,
le spectateur ne peut pas accorder spontanément
une valeur esthétique à… une pissotière.
Je trouve ce dernier argument convainquant,
mais on peut quand même y opposer un autre
argument : l’art contemporain ne peut pas
être comparé aux ères précédentes de
l’histoire de l’art. En effet, si l’art
est fonction de l’état de la civilisation,
alors l’art de la société de consommation
occidentale des XXe et XXIe siècles ne peut
pas être comparé aux arts des sociétés
antérieures, car la société de consommation
occidentale des XXe et XXIe siècles représente
un état de civilisation inédit à bien des
égards.
En résumé, les trois arguments CONTRE l’art
contemporain, ce sont 1° que les artistes
manipulent l’opinion publique pour valoriser
leurs œuvres ; 2° que l’art devient un
prétexte pour faire de la spéculation ; et
enfin, plus fondamentalement, 3° que les
œuvres n’ont plus de valeur artistique,
notamment parce qu’elle ne sont plus le
fruit d’une habileté supérieure.
Après, il faut aussi accepter de voir l’autre
côté des choses : on peut relativiser chaque
argument, comme je l’ai fait dans cette
vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
j’espère que cette vidéo vous a plu,
et puis qu’elle vous sera utile.
Si c’est le cas,
donnez-lui un pouce bleu,
et puis laissez un commentaire,
pour améliorer le référencement de la vidéo
— ce n’est pas grand chose,
et ça m’aide vraiment.
Je suis Romain,
j’étais avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous,
vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.
________________
J’ai une question à vous poser :
vous croyez VRAIMENT
que les gens ont lu
tous les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non.
— sinon on ne pourrait pas parler
de grand-chose.
Eh oui,
il y a vingt-quatre heures
dans une journée,
et il faut travailler,
manger,
dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale,
ce n’est PAS
de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait,
il n’y a pas qu’un seul secret,
il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes
les plus cultivés,
les profs,
et les intellectuels
CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets,
mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer
RAPIDEMENT
et FACILEMENT
leur culture générale,
parce que leur rapport au savoir
A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT
les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références
des personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur
sur n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture
dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique
comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver
DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets,
inscrivez-vous simplement
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de la vidéo.
Croyez-moi :
faites-le,
et vous me remercierez.